[Music]
what's up guys welcome back to our
continued coverage of tekken 7 here at
the playstation competition center
i'm rip joint with mark man and the
focus of this video is going to be on
defense
now movement and playing defensively in
second seven is all about making the
right decisions
let's take a look at some of these ideas
your first intuition might be to just
try to block all attacks
hold back to block all highs and mids
hold down back to block all lows however
tekken 7's strong emphasis on fast mid
and low attacks can make blocking
everything extremely difficult
remember that if you're standing and
guarding though then most of these quick
low attacks will be low damage
sometimes blocking is necessary but
staying still and defending this way
will eventually whittle down your life
bar
so if it's not reasonable to block for
long periods of time how else do you
play defense
the answer is movement movement is a
very crucial aspect of tekken 7.
in fact some of the best ways to play
defense is to create space between you
and your opponent and the best way to do
this is through back dashing and side
stepping
back dashing to create space from your
opponent's attack will give you
opportunities to punish their mistakes
additionally most attacks only track in
one direction so you can side step or
sidewalk to avoid them if you can make a
good weed on the opponent
be careful of homing attacks though as
you pack horizontally to both sides
please know that this doesn't work very
well when your back is to the wall since
you have less space to move
to learn more about wall defense or the
different types of attacks in tekken
check out our playstation competition
center videos dedicated to those topics
another defensive option is using your
character's power crush group indicated
by the red shield icon in the move list
this move has the ability to absorb
opponent attacks and power through
hopefully turning the tide but these
moves can only absorb higher mid attacks
it will universally lose to lows and
throws so it's not a perfect solution
knowing the power crush can lose to lows
and throws it's important to consider
what moves you have to beat low attacks
and also how to escape throws
to escape normal throws you need to
input one of either punch attacks
special command throws will require
specific button inputs to escape
be sure to watch the animation from your
opponent so you can tell what type of
throw they're attempting to grab you
with
learning to defend correctly in tekken 7
takes time the first time you play
against a character you're not really
going to know everything they're
throwing at you
so you really want to take your time and
figure everything out step by step game
by game
and the more matches you play the better
understanding you'll have how to break
down your opponent defensively
that'll do it for this episode this
tutorial was made in partnership with
the playstation competition center team
you can check out
compete.playstation.com to watch
learn and to compete subscribe to the
bne esports
channel for more tutorials and tekken 7
content